hey Kate
give it love give it fear
s
mine
Rebecca I miss you daddy
my feet are killing me again dripping
warm up your feet are a mess I need that
cream
ain't nothing
for you okay let's do the car cut me up
I'm afraid to touch you oh yeah
oh my God I need water
here
get in my car
your job you are
I'm afraid what you're gonna do to my
interior that's all I'm boring here
there's a water for you too
[__]
vodka
[__] yeah
oh my God Richard and I trying I'm just
trying to yeah where's the lotion is why
do you have to be such a dick because my
feet are killing me it's not that I'm a
dick okay she's like gonna kill me and I
need to shave I need makeup and wigs
because I'm pain I'm sorry if I buy you
these things you just lose them what
what I think twice I don't lose them
my decline truly this is really a rock
bottom at this point I'm wearing a pair
of jeans and a [__] scarf
hell America
God Bless the USA God knows I try God
knows I try to please conserve
what day is it today Friday Saturday
what's the date July 29th I think 29th
are you sure yeah it's almost August oh
my birthday's August 4th what are you
gonna do for my birthday I'm celebrating
my birthday in two years I'll eat the
lotion
to put the lotion on the skin or it gets
the hose again your birthday's a fourth
the fourth yeah the fourth of August
19th you're gonna be twenty six I'll be
26 yes and like the double I need the
lotion all right I got it wasn't the
Crystal and the cigarettes
and the phone
accident our injury call Jacob and
Ronnie call Jacob
the queen is back oh um
for me
like this is really weird honestly it's
not busy working or whatever ow what
get this [__]
how do I get rid of this pain
oh
how
what do you do for me what do you do for
my birthday [__]
I'm gonna go to wheel for my birthday
honestly the only place that I lay that
has clubs by the way there are no clubs
anywhere else other than hide it's just
weirdly
there's nowhere else
there's nowhere else in the city I don't
have a job so I can't go to any Studios
I crashed the Chanel show but I don't
want to talk about it anyway it's not
the cruise here I didn't go to the
Versace show yes I did I don't talk
about that um but I crashed the snow
show it was really funny I don't like it
but you know I understood it it's kind
of sad story I actually know it's um
necessary for women
because it was rationality I understand
Sean I know all the soundtracks to all
songs and I understand the fashion of it
but I need to be upgraded you know it's
the idea and emasculating a woman right
now first uh cause I never put a woman
in a suit and um make a woman a jacket
make her a suit oh what the [__] it's
like someone's putting it's like it's a
drinking astronaut so we're putting acid
on my nails really
the [__] protect your feet
um taping up his eye dress no literally
keep some shoes that I buy you yeah okay
thank you Mark
he's gonna mention that you buy me
things but I am you are ah what happens
is you pass out I'm your employee you
pass up and people steal your shoes yeah
I guess so yeah pretty much [__] let's
get around [__] you know it's bum life
it's a thug life out here
ah
foreign
a lot of things but the [__] really
hurts
it's like acid literally
you want me to get your room again maybe
I don't [__] care [__] I need a
phone and I want to party I need an ID
okay I'll get your phone Mike I need you
to help me file for citizenship
I don't know how to do it you know how
to do it
how do I get the documents
I need an ID how do I have a citizenship
I'm not a citizen Mark how do I do it I
don't know
I don't know [__]
if I can get an ID I get a job Mark is
my only favorite I want to ask I'll [__]
can you help me apply for citizenship
where do you go you go to the Federal
Building do you go to City Hall how do
you do it you're so high I need to
become a citizen of the United States of
America shut up it's not about drugs I
want English assistant how do you do it
I don't know
this is Google I think if you walked
into somebody's office right now
ideas
I don't know why not what do you mean
you don't know I'm losing faith
I'm the same old [__] [__] [__]
[__] [__] screw up okay you're
losing faith in me yeah I'm not a [__]
so you're saying I'm a failure I'm sorry
I'm feeling you mark
your demographic is loving that honestly
you know what I mean everybody loves to
see a mess hot mess that fix me up my
fair lady style daddy you're like what
you see if I can fix it
huh you see a pro oh it's a problem to
fix it oh you don't complain don't like
the merchandise pay for it [__]
but he's looking really rich
get you hundreds millions of views huh
Rebecca and everyone who knows Rebecca
do you recognize on the street all over
mark Oliver all right hey are you
Rebecca from Spotify
wait how do you know me uh how do you
see those videos
it's a mustache
what the [__] is this [__] bum [__]
on crack [__] oh [__]
I can't always [__] foot interviews
from the foot series if you held onto
your phone you could probably start your
own YouTube channel and make some money
[__] would be like Jeffree Star or
whatever [__] it [__] I'll go to movies
I wasn't [__] do shooting for me I
did have my own YouTube channel I made
like five [__] short films like 10
views I was very happy doing it
oh it's a lot of work you know I didn't
say oh it is a lot of work also ah
[__] mean crucified
literally it's like oh it's like
tomorrow
ah okay
this will never end until I can smoke oh
what
am I even bleeding you know what I mean
so bizarre so what do you do with your
time
I smoke left I think myself I talk to
myself
and then once a week once every week
that's about it Mike what do you do here
once a week you what I go to West
Hollywood dance in the street because I
don't have IDs I can't get into the
clubs because I'm not a citizen what you
do with your life Mark I've been filming
a bunch of bums
hmm what do you do with your [__]
life [__]
I just can't you know I just can't take
the homeless thing anymore okay nobody
get me out of it
Haha I've been I've been trying for
years I think no you haven't you've
never offered once I didn't I think it
was having one I'm gonna put you in the
hotel room for for a month I do it yeah
you pissed in the room and left oh yeah
obviously should I lost the key folk by
your phone you sell it for drugs I don't
sell it for drugs
but you pass out and you get you're
robbed
because I don't have a house
it's Skid Row you see a phone you steal
it [__]
those are cheap I don't need straight
home for drugs because somebody gonna
call anyway
oh sorry it's a lot of pain right now
because this isn't even how it's not a
crucifixion
because it's like Jesus [__] the [__]
is this how do I hear that I don't
understand it there's no cost or
anything
like possession you know what I mean but
like in pain
like I've done possessions before I've
done seances with possessions so I
understand that but it's like literally
being possessed by pain it's weird it's
different like I understand it's not oh
then I find a pleasure [__] oh my God
I'm Gonna Come
what are you enjoy in your life now
nothing I hate my life I'm so bored up
singing I like music what do you think
is keeping you from having a fulfilling
life an ID son you got a job [__] I want
to go on a fashion
but you don't see that maybe the drugs
are getting in the way my drugs are all
I have life shut up
drugs are happily but you want to see
this over I go to hospital once a week
once a week maybe once a month twice a
month when I'm sober I can't even
[__] walk
I don't even walk four blocks not much
literally
you don't can't mind try it you wanna
try it I don't okay then don't
but don't judge it yeah Mark you're
eating a food oh no [__] yeah like kill
a [__] living creature
sometimes we can [__] vampire how
dare you huh
huh ice meth isn't a lot that's a
substance it's a vampire
fan of all how dare you eat meat I've
seen you either
my honestly I think I think he's really
getting all this Blood you know what I
mean
it is different he's just sticks water
cannibal
yeah you play me that song that's
Hollywood I'm not even so long Cannibal
by Kesha I love that song it was an
Amphitheater
empathy evil like anything but it pays
off
okay
I want to be here I
am kind of ball cannibal cannibal eye
give me something it's like you know
like you don't forget it's like [__] it
there's nothing
he must be suffering right
I really identified with the double and
he's kind of the father I ever had go
back to me some Dead Guy Lily he's a
lived oh [__]
they've got your life
I don't know what to do with you
get me a citizenship a house
you don't think what you're getting me a
house for help oh no it's like the drugs
are getting in the way I'm getting a
house you want me to buy you a house
don't buy me a house yeah for fun buy me
you need a million bucks to buy a house
I don't get a million bucks I pay rent I
can buy myself flour you're gonna get
kicked out of an apartment no I won't
get kicked out of an apartment every
Hotel I put you in your kitchen
that's not true I lose the key I don't
know about that hotel once no but like
the hotel didn't want you back oh they
did I I had to pay somebody off to get
you back in there okay yeah fine yeah
whatever because I pissed on the [__]
yeah fine no because I lost the key mark
you have to pay for the key you idiot
your contacts is a little
miscombobulated
we're at least not much personal time
together based on my like whatever I see
it's like it's like a shock like oh my
God it's Mark it's not all my time alone
it's a
it's a ritual
you know if you could show me in some
way that you are
trying to do the right thing damn hello
my name is Rebecca olsenzo screen test
um let's go with um Cruel Summer and on
freeform
or um honestly my uh pitch I have a
pitch for HBO the stuff for wives and
oil Rebecca Olson's out audition that's
actually like role of Neil Wallace
come on you don't really love me do you
honey and it's just a game isn't it
smoking mirrors right
you didn't tell me I think you're just
like [__] me I just love the idea of
being with me you know what I mean I
like your name and you like my silent we
look really good together you know what
I mean like Carolyn that candy guy
but you know
I'm not sure if you really love me I
mean it's something I don't love you I
don't think I forgot that but
you should be an actor yeah I know I'm
an incredible actress actress sorry
sorry about the dick I think it's a dick
honestly off the drugs it is ridiculous
drugs the Dick's the problem
the dick is the problem get in the way
I want to do drag you know I met the
other day for the first time you heard
of Sandra she's a drag queen no I love
her
Rocco's with skid row and she has no
makeup on like nothing literally just a
shot as as DJ it should be like white
like pale and it's like oh I said it was
mirror
and I met um I also because I love these
girls oh my God and I met at morning
with Michaels oh my God I love meeting
celebrities it doesn't help me a lot
because like I said but I love
celebrities I love the industry in
Hollywood oh my God
like like it's my dream you know what I
mean like when I need a celebrity oh my
God like I remember I met um Jessica
Chastain ones I was like it's my goddess
I mean damn this old Hollywood they see
how like I don't want people to be so
basic like why is that the appeal in old
Hollywood like it was about Grandeur and
gods and and representing things it's
like actually you have to relate to
every man oh you don't even think action
figures
like you are a poor person with uh some
kind of a problem you know what I mean
like why why not Envision wealth we're
not Envision better you're becoming a
celebrity but for all the wrong reasons
for all the right reasons for all the
wrong reasons yeah right if homelessness
pays off first time in history
literally I'm the most famous [__]
[__]
on [__] YouTube other than maybe like
Kim Petras Lily Lily I have more views
than any other friend drag queen
literally those [__] like can you
[__]
[__] like you have no idea I have
hundreds of millions I'm the most
[__] trying on YouTube other than Kim
Petras
I just can't buy you a house right now
or an apartment I don't I don't believe
you're gonna uh I will live in it Mark
if you buy it for me [__] no fine I'll
just go fast just to be on the streets
[__] you [__] no I put you up in a
hotel and you can't even stay there for
two nights well you want to put me up
for one night and I went out [__] up I
offered to put you up for a month fine
let's do it do it two days two days you
were gone you pissed in the room and
split um first it was one night and also
Corey kicked me out and I pissed in the
bucket that he pissed in [__] remember
the context you wasn't there Mike you
didn't piss in a bucket I didn't pissing
the bucket I didn't miss the bucket
really he said you want bucket I don't
want to go to bathroom who's lazy oh
[__]
porn
it's like a war down there it's like a
war zone
this is like my version of a period I
don't know
it's like I'm gonna be a real woman
period it's mostly cranberry but let's
say after this I go out and buy you
shoes and clothes and wigs and phones
and all that [__] that we always do
the next time I see you which is you
know could be days or weeks or months
later about weeks yeah do you wear the
same t-shirt for weeks on end mark
that's something about one dress
one pair of shoes a necklace and a top
that's the top and a perfume
no one and we talked about staying at
the hotel across the street got it for a
hundred for a month fine deal deal
do it test me one month give me a month
I'm ready and well yes I'm ready okay
okay we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
do it right now oh
we'll see what you do with the hotel
room for a month right
I just want to jerk off honestly I
didn't even sleep because I need like
someone to jerk off or [__] so I need a
[__] move
I want to see me outside charge your
phone and masturbate literally and [__]
them [__] ages
freaking email oh my goddess the effort
and lifestyle I need a secretary
honestly I need an agent a secretary I
got an agent a butler and a chef do you
see I'm satisfied do I have to change my
name
my real name is what is my real name
Mark uh Sasha or something no it Ishmael
Ishmael yeah
what's your last name Saudi s-o-u-d-i
I emigrated here like three four years
ago I tried my first time but um how to
mix up with the lawyer and now I'm a
[__] uh illegal immigrant unless I'm
homeless because
oh [__] I don't know how to apply for
him I don't understand [__] it's more
conveniently
enough convenience either but it just
happened I remember like I go up really
rich too you know what I mean I just got
high one dude well I went to New York
and I was like um I couldn't afford like
[__] it it's gonna work when's the last
time you talked to your parents um I
don't talk to I don't talk to my mom
anymore and my dad um
brought me here some people apartment
[__] spot what do you I don't mean to
pry but why do you not speak with your
mom
um I don't know like she's just [__]
we got in a fight when I [__] came
out when I was 14. and um
it's just um I don't know her number I
know how to contact her
we just [__] thought about it and I
remember the facts okay that's because
you don't have a phone no mark because I
don't know her number she lives like she
moved away my friend's gone divorced and
she moved away Facebook Instagram stuff
like that no she doesn't have a Facebook
Italy she's very simple she's very
different she's very simple she's a
beautiful woman you know like innocence
like like
pure unequivocal innocence you have
siblings huh you have a sister right I
wish I wish I had two sisters I have one
younger brother we don't get along
who's that full about when we were kids
and gonna fight over right and he blamed
me and I put in him I was like can't
able you know what I mean like [__]
and whatever
um yeah anyway
yeah I have one younger brother his name
is model on called Bootsy growing up
that's about it
I have a cousin her name is nurian
I don't have anything left right now I
have nothing like shut up
oh this is foot pain
let me get you some stuff some shoes
some phones some phones a ray phone
let's see how long you can hang on to it
all right um
thank God
vodka
hour
or something else Mike and Crystal [__]
and water you guys have water
can you guys see the water
thanks
oh my God
it's not just about burning of the white
shoe I mean but I've been a desert water
signature has water
like
is this a thing for me like water like
food I gotta when I got food oh my God I
love food but water being honest has
taught me the meaning of water see like
I spent like that's all I do is I go to
Starbucks and I get a free water cup you
know what I mean and then I'll go buy my
smoke Maybe
you know it's my life really I walk
around it's like picking up cigarette
butts off the side of the road really
and getting free water from Starbucks
and it really taught me the [__]
value of water
such a gift that sensation you know what
I mean
like instant I said oh my God
oh
it's still pure it's not like thought
anymore
you know
oh my God this is pain [__]